hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game I was played in round five of
the Phaedo World Team Championship
the match is Kazakhstan vs. Russia and
on board one we have arena tomba versus
former vultures championship challenger
Sergei Kerrigan and it's really a
wonderful game a lot of history to it
I'm gonna walk you through everything
that happens as the positions that arise
in this game have been played plenty of
times between some of the strongest
players in history so it will be very
interesting and also we do have a couple
of nice photos from this event there you
have it this is the match Russia versus
Kazakhstan there you have it it seems
that neppo is not playing and raking
took his place but you know nothing out
of the ordinary here although I did I
did the gets to see this it seems like a
some sort of a smartphone mask or
something but as I don't think
smartphones are allowed in there could
be could be a chocolate or something
from Kazakhstan as you know like Hikaru
is sponsored by Red Bull maybe mr. um
Bob is sponsored by this chocolate
factory so it could be it could be a
subtle attempt at you know at
advertising this chocolate or or maybe
not maybe he's just you know brought a
snack it's hard to tell and we also have
a very nice photo of the Russian team
there you have it Grichuk Artemyev and
rakin and Kuryakin and I do not
recognize the gentleman on the far right
but you know as I'm also here to learn
if any of you do recognize him do do
sharing the in the comments below so
without further ado let's check out this
game involve with the white pieces opens
with d4 and okay we have Knight to f6 c4
we have e 6 sorry about that
Knight to f3 and d5 so as you can see
things haven't changed all that much
since the 1914 tournament in st.
Petersburg the Queens gambit the clients
still on the board and well modern
players will play it a bit differently
but you know interesting to see how
chess developed over over you know the
last century Bishop to e7 the standard
line and we have g3 now okay we have
castles Bishop to G to D captures on c4
and now white immediately takes
advantage of this very nice c5 outpost
and
places his night here so now the knight
and Bishop control the board very nicely
the bishop slicing all the way through
the board the black for the moment is up
upon we have c5 trying to get rid of his
double spawn which makes sense you'd
want to exchange your flank pawn for
whites a central point D captures on c5
Queen captures Knight captures and now
Bishop captures on c5 and here you could
capture the c-4 point immediately but
doesn't there's no rush it's not like
black can defend it or anything what
just plays Bishop to b2 and of course
you cannot play something like b5 the
bishop is too powerful here you can see
that a black still has to figure out how
to develop his queen side and here we
have Knight to d5 it's in it's not a new
move it has played before but for
historical reference and Knight the c6
was played here Anand played this move
against Richard report in the 2019 Tata
Steel chess turn in that game ended in a
draw but he will have Knight to d5 and
okay now why does capture we have knife
captors in c4 as this is now the knight
is blocking the bishops attack towards
the rook we have Knights the c6 and now
rook the c1 place in developing the rook
also the Bishop on c5 is undeveloped so
some nasty discoveries could be made if
black doesn't do anything about this and
here also an interesting move Bishop to
d7 was played in the 2015 feeder World
Cup in Baku Azerbaijan our top I've
played it against the Greece shock that
game also ended in a draw but here we
have Bishop to e7 correcting goes for
this move this move was played in 1991
Anatoly Karpov played this move against
Aleksandr borovsky
okay Bishop to e7 getting at this Bishop
out of harm's way you know in time and
now we have just castles here the game
differentiates from the game belowski
Karpov SB lasting and ended with Knight
d2 III but okay here we have castles
byamba
and now comes Rock to d8 and this is now
a new game and now we have a position
that has never been reached before
or do we I actually do mean something by
this but I will explain in a few moves
we have night DITA III biome live Knight
captures with Bishop captures on III and
now Bishop to d7 now this Bishop is
coming over to e8 rook F to D 1 jimbo
just develops his other rook and Bishop
to EA and now through a different set of
moves you know no with a different move
order we once again reach the same exact
position Karpov head against the
velocity head against Anatoly Karpov in
1991 rook captures on d8 we have rook
captures on d8 and now a three and here
in 1991 Karpov continued with Knight to
d4 that game also ended in a draw I have
to point to this altar but here we have
h5 by kurakin so it seems that now it's
kurakin who again makes a new move and
we have a position that has never been
reached before and from now on we will
not be returning to any famous games but
ok h5 and it's basically here from move
18 that the game really starts now it's
hard to imagine that Kerrigan doesn't
know about that game between Bella
Erskine Karpov
but you know then again who knows ok we
have before here whitey grabs more space
on the Queen side and now h4 Cara King
tries to exchange to create some
weaknesses on the King side and it's
interesting here white captures with the
G captures on h4 and you might think why
would why to do this I mean wouldn't it
be better if you know you don't mess up
your own pawn structure it's interesting
for example if you just try King f1 you
want to maybe bring your King into the
game allah captures captures and then
black can go g5 by can go f5 and you
would have this position where white
would just not have a messed up pawn
structure on the Kings side so it's very
interesting that the embargoes for G
captures on h4 but it's interesting if
black were to go Bishop captures on h4
immediately then white could have some
Knights to a5 ideas which would create
some problems for black on the Queen
side maybe maybe this is your buyers
idea for example if Knight captures pawn
characters you can also mess up your
pawn structure here but here your bishop
pair will be extremely strong and you
will be able to eliminate blacks Queen
side pawns
and maybe create some threats with your
with your well double-date point but
okay
hereafter G characters on h4 we have
Knights to d4 going again for Karpov
move Bishop captures rook captures on d4
and now III and now while you can
capture on h4 here Carter King decides
to bring the route back to help out with
the defense of the Queen side and also
now the bishop will be able to capture
here the shop capture son b7 we have
Bishop captures on h4 and now just
Knight to e5 and I centralizing move for
whites Knight Bishop to f6 attacking the
undefended night here and now rook the
c5 just defending that night King to f8
kurakin improves the position of the
King and now Bishop back to e4 here
white white the definitely wouldn't mind
going b5 a 5 or a 4 a 5 and trying to
create a passport on the Queen side so
here a six-car can of course doesn't
allow it to the Bishop and pawn now
create a blockage on the Queen side and
we have f4 here by white and okay Bishop
to b5 now kurakin created this blockade
although white has a two-to-one
advantage on the Queen side which is
often a huge deal I mean you can always
create a passed pawn most of the times
so here kirkin just blocks this and on
the King said it's three points each so
maybe he can hold this regardless of
being down upon rook the c7 now by white
attacking of course in the f7 point so
you do have to defend it Cara King can
choose to go back with the bishop but
you really like her Bishop on b5 you
don't want to do this so here kurakin
decides to go for a different plan
he plays Bishop captures on e5 with F
captures on e5 and now black plays g5
Cara can created some room for his King
and g7 also he doesn't want to allow
white to expand on the King side he
wants this point to remain an h2 for you
know perhaps to be a potential future
target
King to f2 white starts improving the
position of the King but now just
rook the D to check forcing the King to
keep an eye on the h2 pawn king to g3
and now kink the g7 okay we have looked
the c3 here white has to keep an eye on
the a3 and the
reponse oh the black rook does not
attack them rook to d1
kurakin just waiting to see what whites
plan will be as he doesn't really have
an active plan himself Bishop to f3 now
forcing the rogue back rook to g1 check
King to f2 and now rook to f1 trip
kurakin is now trying to repeat moves
King to g3 King
aroof to g1 check King to have to and
now troop to f1 again with check we have
King to g2 now not repeating King to g3
because that that would allow Kerrigan
to go for a threefold repetition and
Yuma is not interested in a draw even
against the player a strongest kurakin
that's you know to be to be commended
you know that's how real chess is played
rook to a-1 with Bishop to h5 now maybe
with ideas of going after the f7 pawn
but white still has to figure out how to
get get out of all the checks rotate you
check we have King to g3 and not just
rook to e1 trying to repeat some
checking ideas we have King to have two
and now just look way to check and with
this check they have reached time
control this is move 40 so now they can
you know just relax for a moment King to
g3 look back to a1 and now just h3 this
pawn will no longer be a target on h2
white you know you do have to make a
pawn move otherwise you know there's
even the danger of the 50 move rule
being forced into a draw if you know no
pawns are captured or moved
rook to 82 we have kink the g4 now
threatening to capture here and now just
look the g2 check whitening has to go
back we look back to a2 and now comes
rushing back to g4 so how is how is you
involve you know if he doesn't want a
draw how can he do something about this
well okay now the bishop is protecting
the h3 pawn and perhaps the King can now
be activated via some central squares
Bishop to e2 check we have came to e4
and now you don't want to capture here
if you capture here then the the ending
will be most likely winning for white
white can just you know get his King
into the game even if the rook blocks it
then this rook can pick up the pawn here
not not gonna be a problem for white but
okay after King two before we have
better
to f1 king back to f3 and Bishop to g2
check now kink the g3 Bishop to f1 and
now Bishop to f3 a very important move
as now the king will try to march up the
board and the bishop will be preventing
any checks from the rook along the
second-ranked with russia back to be 5
by kurakin and now h4 white doesn't
white still not interested in a draw G
captures we have King captures on h4 and
now just f6 we have Bush or 24 and here
black has to make a decision he can
either push f5 but this would create
some weaknesses this pawn would now be
weak its analyte where the rook and
Bishop could be potentially used to win
the point and also you give the White
King some extra squares he can use you
know to harass blacks position
so here kirkin makes a concrete decision
he plays F captures an e5 a temporary
pawn sacrifice by white but now his King
can enter the game King g5 Bishop still
not allowing any checks from the black
rook we have King to f7 and now comes
Luke the c7 check now the King has to
fall back and now came to f6 these bones
are now you know easy prey for the white
king rook captures on a3 white had to
calculate perfectly will he be able to
give up these reap on King captures on
e6
and now of course the black is not in
time to capture yet another pawn due to
Luke the CH checkmate
so here black has the first attack to
rook rook to b8 ass or King today
attacking the rook King deuce it's
defending and now comes Luke captures on
e3 now the pawn can be captured and
Bishop to d5 and this is a beautiful
formation that I'm sure will will haunt
Kerrigan for a very long time but you'll
see what I mean by this first
rook to e1 bye-bye Carolyn you do not
want to keep this rook behind the bishop
and king so the bishop cannot be cannot
threaten any ideas for example if you
try something like a bishop three six
look to see it will be checkmate
so there there's really no time to go
pawn grabbing here and here we have a
very nice idea
6.now will not be all that impressive
because rook to d1 check will just force
the butcher back and now you might fall
into a trap like this rope captures
captures captures and okay
black will not win this game it's a draw
because after you capture Black has a
wrong wrong pawn as the bishop is light
square and the pawn and Queens on a dark
square you will not be able to win this
game but still it would be it would be a
shame to you know I play something like
this so first look the g7 and this is
now a beautiful idea
now you can see that the King and the
bishop create a very large wall here
against the black ink so the the King
and Bishop are controlling five squares
in front of the black King so you really
have to keep an eye on for any checks as
your king is not going anywhere
so here we have looked the d1 now again
not allowing this Bishop to move okay
check would be met with bishop here so
it will not be checked made immediately
but it's very interesting if hurricane
could push his pawn it it'd be great but
he's just not in time for example if
rook checks bishop has to block now you
can play Bishop f7 just attack the pin
piece and after some checks for example
check King see here check you can go
King before check King c4 check you can
go King be free Ruby one check King C
two attacks the rook and now you will
well you will lose either a rook or a
bishop it will not I mean it will not be
very pleasant so instead of that after
this rook to g7 would have looked a d1
not allowing this check to be followed
by Bishop to f7 now play now comes King
captures on e5 so unfortunately for
kurakin he was not able to push his
passed pawn and now rook the b1 not
going after this pawn with King back to
d6 and now here with rook to d1 this is
the best idea for Cara can you just
place your look behind the bishop so
there are no tricks here and you are
definitely in this game the material is
equal and even though your King isn't in
all that of an impressive position you
know it is playable here after King
capped King the six kirkin decided to
play rook captures on b4 so now he's
actually
upon and if he can start pushing his
passport perhaps he can even win this
game and the car can calculated
precisely if Luke g8 check here Bishop
has the block Bishop f7 now there's no e
pawn so you can defend with rook to e4
and now even if this was played and you
know everything is exchanged the king is
in time to pick up this pond and it's a
draw
so perhaps Carson wasn't interested I
mean of course he wasn't thinking about
winning this game but I think hurricane
thought that this was a draw but he
missed one very important move so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the move that kurakin missed for
white I'll give you a couple of seconds
as it's a it's a quite an interesting
position it can happen in your own games
quite often I mean if you have a
superior position of your king you know
against your opponent's king and your
opponent is up a pawn I mean it's a it's
a rook and Bishop against rook and
Bishop it can happen to anyone it's a
nice nice to know D these things so I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent and
game player as even the great defender
like Sarah gave kurakin you know the
minister of defense wasn't able to spot
this one and for those of you who you
know just one injured rook to e7 and now
we just returned to the idea that the
bishop and King are creating this
powerful wall against the black King and
any Czech given now will be checkmate as
there's no way for you to block this you
can't go rook see for the bishop covers
that square so here there really are no
moves that Kerrigan can play Cara can't
ride Bishop to d7 it's a it's a peace
sacrifice that well at least if if
Kerrigan can survive checkmate he does
have a passed pawn so maybe he can do
something with this but not not in time
rook chapters on d6 was played King to
e8 and now rook to e7 check and now if
the King goes back the problem is rook
to h7 again you cannot you cannot
prevent any any checkmates now rook to
b6 of course will be followed with
Bishop here again there's no there's no
stopping this you cannot go here to
prevent it to you there's I mean nothing
to do so after rook to
seven pink the f8 was played and now
just rook the f7 check again you know
you can go here because then a nasty
discovery like this picks up the rook
you have to go back and now again an
interesting move a really a fun maneuver
you do want to memorize this one rook to
f3 you don't allow the rook the King to
move if the King moves then rook here to
f8 will be checkmate so black has to
make a move again if you go route b6
this check King here it's checkmate so
no checks are possible
Luke the default was played kurakin does
not allow the bishop to move but now
comes Luke the b3 now of course you
threaten this checkmate because the King
is covering these squares and the bishop
still covers f7 so it will be checkmate
if the three squares in front of the
black King are covered and you deliver
check if the King is on the back rank it
is checkmate
so King to f8 you don't want to try and
escape the g7 and now this was the de
nifty little maneuver that white pulled
again feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move for white
here again I'll give you a couple of
seconds dad that was the idea rook to f3
to b3 and now of course congratulations
to everyone who was able to do it and
for those we just wanna enjoy a short
road back to g3
now the king has nowhere to go the king
is covering East 7 the bishop is
covering f7 the rook is covering g7 so
everything is you know defended the rook
will land on g8 and this will be
checkmate as the king has nowhere to go
if you go back still doesn't matter the
king is covering d7 so it was in this
position I'm all 68 that Sergei Carrick
in formal Chess Championship Challenger
resigned to the game any move you make
ends in Ruby Jade checkmate or you can
capture the bishop but then it's just a
lost game no point in trying something
like this so yeah a very impressive
victory for for Grandmaster from
Kazakhstan arena Kimba really you know
so many players survive this as we
already mentioned Anand played at a good
Easter play that even Karpov plated
against Bill asked in 1991 so you know
this line was repeated a lot a lot of
times and now in 2019
kara can fals the victim to it simply no
one is immune
I mean it's just the way it just works
it can happen to anyone so a wonderful
victory for inner-tube I've even though
Kazakhstan lost the match three to one
everyone else lost but still you know
you might will remember this day as the
day he defeated Kirk in in a line you
know and that was pretty much
bulletproof over there I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you are enjoying my
short coverage of the affiliate World
Team Championship we're gonna show one
other game today I still haven't decided
which one but then we are going to talk
about the standings a bit more and today
more rounds are played so maybe maybe
even a game from round six we'll see I
would like to thank miles Brown largest
wolf is bid Nia he he deep David Lander
and eunsuh dead ski for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and short not announcement but
you know an info I do have another
channel called
agamotto Salter channel which I don't
really use that often maybe once or
maybe once in two months but sometimes I
will upload something then maybe maybe
video game wise or maybe I will review a
book still haven't reviewed any books
but I am planning to do it so if you're
interested I I tried this video game
called slate aspire it's really
interesting you know really a strategic
game logical game if you enjoy games
like those do check it out I will put a
link to it in the description below it
will be the first thing you see so maybe
if you enjoy it you know do check it out
Robert yeah that's the game I think oh
and I will see you soon